Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Lucas from Massachusetts. Lucas,
welcome to the show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Hi. I'm ecstatic right
now because I didn't get to ask my question last
week. But here's my question, please. So a lot of
people are optimistic about the war in Ukraine
because of the Ukrainians advances. I'm not.
And here's why. Okay. I think that I worry that if
the GOP takes back Congress, it will block Ukraine
funding and side with Putin. What do you think?
Speaker 1: I think they almost certainly will.
Now, just as a heads up, you've got discord
notifications blinking in the background,
and that is a faux pas during the phone call.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 1: So if you can get those turned
off, that would be really great. I think
you were absolutely correct. And when the
if Republicans get the opportunity to stop
the funding to Ukraine, they will do it under
the guise of we have to take care of America
first. That's what they're saying. And of
course, many people will look at it and say,
this is another way that you're playing soft with
Putin. And they'll say it's not about playing soft
with Putin. It's about we need to deal with crime
and immigration and all these different things.
And of course, we can walk and chew gum at the
same time. But yeah, they will they will try to
at least cut funding to Ukraine. And that's
the type of explanation that they'll give.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you for answering
my question. I've heard a lot of different
perspectives on it. I'm glad to hear yours.
Speaker 1: All right, Lucas, thank you very much.
Speaker 3: Welcome.
Speaker 1: All right. There we go. O